at the end of every week we have we read
emails people asking for advice it's
called unhelpful advice okay and can you
just do the segment and then I will walk
you to the car
here test to your testimony go ahead
babe I mean okay I'm hopeful advice with
Bobby
kalila and Santa Monica this question is
from Stephen hey friends I am a 20 year
old male for the last year and a half
I've been clean and working out and
motivated my dream is to move to LA to
do stand-up the kicker is my fiance and
I just had a beautiful baby boy so being
a provider I am stuck delivering Red
Bull which is an okay job and it pays
the bills but I [ __ ] hate it I would
be able to go for it but if I wasn't a
father or provider I don't want to leave
my family and be that deadbeat dad but
continuing this shitty job makes me die
inside I feel like a waste of a human
and potential any ideas yeah put the kid
up for adoption so bring the kid and the
wife with you to Los Angeles obviously
and of course and I know your way to you
I'm gonna be having a kid but that's the
reality 23 years old it's fine it's fine
so have that kid and let that motivate
you but bring your child and your wife
to your dream to Los Angeles where you
can follow your dream yeah but did you
start here no New York yeah so I you
know I would wherever he lives he should
go up for three years yeah you know like
yeah right you can write they dude when
you're delivering Red Bull there is zero
reason why you can't be writing jokes
all the time yeah that's a lot of time
to write so it's actually a perfect job
for you to think and write and you know
who was a single father who raised I
think this is Josh wolf yeah yeah Josh
wolf had four kids and he raised them by
himself yeah young to write amazing a
great because energy is young yeah so no
excuses bro yeah in terms of white dudes
that are funny he's in my top three for
sure yeah you're my top five hey anyway
isn't it yeah it's a any shows yeah you
want to plug it shows you have Viet
comedy mix in Vancouver May 4th 5th and
6th you'll be doing 100 seat venue with
a comedy job be that's obnoxious or
something don't say that no that's quite
a job coming up nothing no you do you
have a few I have to update your website
go to my lovely her Grasso she does she
does all my she does everything I change
his pants all the stuff she bought she
bought she started this whole thing she
does actually you're an effective woman
that's it we're not allowed to know he's
in cahoots with the [ __ ] the guy
going on for two years every weekend its
job with you yeah yeah every week every
text but you know shabu put the jealousy
in a man he's a beautiful because like
yes you do you're you cried on this part
there you go again Barisan oh poor thing
face your fears videotape it and watch
it over and over
Brian we've had some good guess but I
think you're like one of the best man I
really do it you're so just funny and I
love you all right Bryan Callen
everybody that was amazing thank you
we'll be back guys
[Music]